with your imagination you can create
anything
where's the food the pants with a kind
of school supplies they want you to go
meet with them in New York they want you
to give us millions of dollars I'm not
coming back without a suitcase full of
money
you must be Isabel yes I'm Teresa so
nice to meet you
so we have a list of priorities I have
the caterers on the line I'm really
sorry about that you just caught me at a
very busy time my daughters getting
married this weekend come to the wedding
we can get to know each other better I
pronounce you husband and wife
Congrats
every smile
good you made it Isabelle runs an
orphanage in India that I'm thinking of
fighting oh yeah what are you doing here
I didn't know hi Isabel ray I told you
that I would call you that you didn't
this is strange to see Oscar again
he's good-looking man now but back then
I must have really been something
I'm about to donate a small fortune to
the orphans Isabelle runs in India I
don't trust your wife she's gonna give
you money for your charity you're gonna
question her integrity huh 20 million
what does she want
[Music]
you know that you're not the only one
affected by this right we don't get to
choose
you tell her all right well I want to
know everything
what did you do
you
[Music]
you